the ribosome who I mentioned a little
while back can make an elephant one
molecule at a time ribosomes are slow
they run at about one molecule a second
but ribosomes make ribosomes so you have
trillions of them and that makes an
elephant in the same way these little
assembly robots I'm describing can make
giant structures
at heart because of the robot can make
the robot so more recently to my
students Amira and Miana had a nature
communication paper showing how this
robot can be made out of the parts it's
making so the robots can make the robot
so you build up the capacity of robotic
assembly
the following is a conversation with
Neil gershenfeld the director of MIT is
Center for bits and atoms an amazing
laboratory that is breaking down
boundaries between the digital and
physical worlds fabricating objects and
machines at all scales of reality
including robots and automata that can
build copies of themselves and
self-assemble into complex structures
his work inspires Millions across the
world as part of the maker movement to
build cool stuff
to create the very act that makes life
so beautiful and fun
this is Alex Friedman podcast to support
it please check out our sponsors in the
description and now dear friends here's
Neil gershenfeld
you have spent your life working at the
boundary between bits and atoms so the
digital and the physical what have you
learned about engineering and about
nature reality from uh working at this
divide trying to bridge this divide I
learned why Von Neumann and Turing made
fundamental mistakes
um it's I learned the secret of life
yeah
um I I learned how to solve many of the
world's most important problems which
all sound presumptuous but all of those
are things I learned at that boundary
okay so uh touring and Von Neumann let's
start there some of the most impactful
important humans who have ever lived in
Computing why were they wrong so I
worked with Andy Gleason who is
touring's counterparts so just just for
background if anybody doesn't know
Turing is credited with the modern
architecture of computing
among many other things Andy Gleason was
his U.S counterpart and you might not
have heard of Andy Gleason but you might
have heard of the Hilbert problems and
Andy Gleason solved the fifth one
so he was a really notable mathematician
during the war he was throwing his
counterpart then van Neumann is credited
with the modern architecture of
computing and one of his students was
Marvin Minsky so I could ask Marvin what
Johnny was thinking and I could ask Andy
what Alan was thinking
and what came out from that what I came
to appreciate
as background I never understood the
difference between computer science and
physical science but
turing's machine that's the foundation
of modern Computing has a simple physics
mistake
which is the head is distinct from the
tape so in the turing machine there's a
head that programmatically moves and
reads and writes a tape the head is
distinct from the tape which means
Persistence of information is separate
from interaction with information yeah
then van Neumann wrote deeply and
beautifully about many things but not
Computing he wrote a horrible men memo
called the first draft of a report in
the edvac which is how you program a
very early computer in it he essentially
roughly took turing's architecture and
built it into a machine
so the legacy of that is the computer
somebody's using to watch this is
spending much of its effort moving
information from Storage Transit
transistors to processing transistors
even though they have the same
computational complexity so in computer
science when you learn about Computing
there's a ridiculous taxonomy of about a
hundred different models of computation
but they're all fictions in physics a
patch of space occupies space
it stores state it takes time to Transit
and you can interact that is the only
model of computation that's physical
everything else is a fiction
so I I really came to appreciate that a
few years back when I did a keynote for
the annual meeting of the supercomputer
industry and then went into the halls
and spent time with the supercomputer
Builders and came to appreciate
see if you're familiar with the movie
The Metropolis uh people would Frolic
upstairs in the gardens and down in the
basement people would move levers and
that's how Computing exists today that
we pretend software is not physical it's
separate from hardware and the whole
Canon of Computer Science is based on
this fiction that bits aren't
constrained by atoms but all sorts of
scaling issues and Computing come from
that boundary but all sorts of
opportunities come from that boundary
and so you can trace it all the way back
to turing's machine making this mistake
between the head and the tape Von
Neumann in in
um create he never called it vinomen's
architecture he wrote about it in this
Dreadful memo and then he wrote
beautifully about other things we'll
talk about now to end a long answer
Turing and Von Neumann both knew this so
all of the Canon of computer scientists
credits them for what was never meant to
be a computer architecture both Turing
and Von Neumann ended their life
studying exactly how software becomes
Hardware so van Neumann studied
self-reproducing automata how a machine
communicates its own construction a
touring studied morphogenesis how genes
give rise to form they ended their life
studying the embodiment of computation
something that's been forgotten by the
Canon of computing but developed sort of
off to the sides by a really interesting
lineage
so there's no distinction between the
head and the tape between the computer
and the computation it is all
computation right so I never understood
the difference between computer science
and physical science and working at that
boundary helped lead to things like my
lab was part of doing with a number of
interesting collaborators the first
faster than classical Quantum
computations we were part of a
collaboration creating the minimal
synthetic organism where you design life
in a computer those both involve
domains where you just can't separate
Hardware from software the embodiment of
computation is embodied in these really
profound ways
so the first quantum computations
synthetic life so in the space of
biology
so space of physics at the lowest level
in the space of biology at the lowest
level
so uh let's talk about CBA Center of
bits and atoms what's the origin story
of this MIT legendary MIT Center that
you're a part of creating
in high school I really wanted to go to
vocational school where you learned to
weld and fix cars and build houses
and I was told no you're smart you have
to sit in a room and nobody could
explain to me why I couldn't
go to Vocational School
uh I then worked at Bell labs this
wonderful place uh before deregulation
legendary place and I would get Union
grievances because I would go into the
workshop and try to make something and
they would say no you're smart you have
to tell somebody what to do
and it wasn't until MIT and I'll explain
how CBA started but I could create CBA
that I came to understand this is a
mistake that dates back to the
Renaissance so in the Renaissance the
liberal arts emerged and liberal doesn't
mean politically liberal this was the
path to Liberation birth of humanism and
so the liberal arts with the Trivium
quadrivium roughly language Natural
Science and
at that moment what emerged was this
Dreadful concept of the ill liberal arts
so anything that wasn't the liberal arts
was for commercial gain and was just
making stuff and wasn't valid for
serious study and so that's why we're
left with learning to weld wasn't a
subject for serious study
um but the means of expression of
changed since the Renaissance so micro
Machining or embedded coding is every
bit as expressive as painting a painting
or writing a sonnet so uh never
understanding this difference between
computer science and physical science
uh the path that led me to create CBA
with colleagues was
I was what's called a junior fellow at
Harvard I was visiting MIT through
Marvin because I was interested in the
physics of musical instruments I
uh this will be another slight
aggression I uh and Cornell I would
study Physics and and then I would cross
the street and go to the music
department where I played the bassoon
and I would trim reads and play the
reads right and they'd be beautiful but
then they'd get soggy and then I
discovered in the basement of the music
department at Cornell was David Borden
uh who you might not have heard of but
it's legendary electronic music because
he was really the first electronic
musician so Bob Moog who invented um
Moog synthesizers was a physics student
at Cornell like me crossing the street
and eventually he was kicked out and
invented electronic music David Borden
was the first musician who created
electronic music so he's legendary for
people like Phil glass and Steve Reich
and so that got me thinking about I
would behave as a scientist in the music
department but not in in the physics
department but not in the music
department got me thinking about what's
the computational capacity of a musical
instrument
and through Marvin he introduced me to
Todd mackover at the media lab who was
just about to start a project with Yo-Yo
Ma
um that led to a collaboration uh to
instrumenticello to to extract yoyo's
data and bring it out into computational
environments what is the computational
capacity of a musical instrument as we
continue on this tangent and when we
shall return to CBA yeah so
one part of that is to understand the
Computing and if you look at like the
finest time scale and length scale you
need to model the physics it's not
heroic you know a a good GPU can do
teraflops today that used to be a
national class supercomputer now it's
just a GPU and that's about if you take
the time scales and length scales
relevant for the physics that's about
the scale of the physics Computing for
yoyo it was really driving it was he's
completely unsentimental about the strad
it's not that it makes some magical
Wiggles in the sound wave it's its
performance as a controller how he can
manipulate it as an interface device
interface between one and one exactly
human sound okay and so so what it led
to was I had started by thinking about
Ops per second but the yoyo's question
was really
um resolution and bandwidth it's
um how fast can you measure what he does
and
um uh the the the bandwidth and the
resolution of detecting his controls and
then mapping them into sounds and what
what we found what he found was if you
instrument everything he does and
connect it to almost anything it sounds
like yo-yo that that the magic is in the
control not in ineffable details in how
the wood Wiggles and so with yo-yo and
Todd that led to a piece and towards the
end I asked yo-yo what what it would
take for him to get rid of his Strat and
use our stuff and his answer was just
Logistics it was at that time our stuff
was like a rack of electronics and lots
of cables and some grad students to to
make it work once the technology becomes
as invisible as the strad then sure
absolutely he would take it and by the
way as a footnote on the footnote an
accident in the sensing of yoyo's cello
led to a hundred million dollar a year
Auto Safety business to control airbags
and cars how did that work I had to
instrument the bow without interfering
with it so I um set up
um local electromagnetic fields where I
would um detect
um how those fields interact with the
bow he's playing but we had a problem
that his hand whenever his hand got near
these sensing Fields I would start
sensing his hand rather than the
materials on the bow
and I didn't quite understand what was
going on with those that that
interference so my very first grad
student ever Josh Smith
did a thesis on tomography with electric
Fields how to see in 3d with electric
fields
then through Todd and at that point
research scientists my lab Joe Paradiso
it led to a collaboration with uh Penn
and Teller who
um where we did a magic trick in Las
Vegas to contact Houdini and sort of
these fields are sort of like you know
contacting spirits
so we did a magic trick in Las Vegas and
then the the crazy thing that happened
after that was uh Phil ritmuller came
running into my lab he worked with um
this became with Honda and NEC airbags
were killing infants and rear-facing
child seats
um cars need to distinguish
a front-facing adult where you'd save
the life versus a bag of groceries where
you don't need to fire the airbag versus
the rear-facing infant where you would
kill it and so the the the seat need to
in effect see in 3d to understand the
occupants and so we took the pen and
Teller magic trick derived from Josh's
thesis from yo-yo's Cello to an auto
show and all the card companies said
great when can we buy it and so that
became ellisis and it was 100 million
dollar a year business making sensors
there wasn't a lot of publicity because
it was in the car so the car didn't kill
you
so they didn't sort of advertise we have
nice sensors so the car doesn't kill you
but it became a leading Auto Safety
sensor and that started from the cello
and the question of the computational
capacity musical instrument right so now
to get back to
MIT I was spending a lot of outside time
at IBM research that had gods of the
foundations of computing
um this is amazing people there and I'd
always expected to go to IBM to take
over a lab but at the last minute
pivoted and came to MIT to take a
position
in the media lab and start what became
the predecessor to CBA media lab is well
known for Nicholas negroponte what's
less well known is the role of Jerry
Wiesner so Jerry was mit's president
before that Kennedy science advisor
grand old man of science at the end of
his life he was frustrated by how
knowledge was segregated
and so he wanted to create a department
of none of the above a department for
work that didn't fit in departments
and the media lab in a sense was a cover
story for him to hide a department it as
mit's president towards the end of his
tenure if he said I'm going to make a
department for things that don't fit in
departments the Departments would have
screamed but everybody was sort of
paying attention to Nicholas creating
the media lab and Jerry kind of hid in
in it a department called Media Arts and
Sciences it's really the department of
none of the above
and Jerry explaining that and Nicholas
then confirming it is really why I
pivoted and went to MIT
um because my students who helped create
Quantum Computing or synthetic life get
degrees from Media Arts and Sciences
this department of none of the above
so that led to coming to MIT yeah with
um uh Todd and Joe Paradiso and my
colleague we started a Consortium called
things that think and this was around
the birth of Internet of things and
um RFID but then we started doing things
like work we can discuss that became the
beginnings of quantum Computing and
cryptography and materials and logic and
microfluidics and those needed
uh much more significant infrastructure
and were much longer research arcs so
with a bigger team of about 20 people we
wrote a proposal to the NSF to assemble
one of every tool to make anything of
any size was roughly the proposal one of
any tool to make anything of any size
yeah so they're usually nanometers
micrometers millimeters meters are
segregated input and output is
segregated we wanted to look just very
literally how digital becomes physical
and physical becomes digital and
fortunately we got NSF on a good day and
they funded this facility of one of
almost every tool to make anything and
so uh with
um a group of core colleagues
um that included Joe Jacobson like
trying Scott minnellis we launched CBA
and so you're talking about nanoscale
micro scale nanostructures
microstructures macro structures
electron microscopes and focused on beam
probes for nanostructures laser micro
Machining and x-ray microtomography for
microstructures multi-axis Machining and
3D printing for macro structures just
some examples what are we talking about
in terms of scale how can we build tiny
things and big things all in one place
yeah so a well-equipped research lab has
the sort of tools we're talking about
but they're segregated in different
places they're typically also run by
technicians where you then have an
account and a project and you charge all
of these tools are essentially
when you don't know what you're doing
not when you do know what you're doing
in that they're they're when you need to
work across length scales where we don't
once projects are running in this
facility we don't charge for time you
don't make a formal proposal to schedule
and the users really run the tools and
it's for work that's kind of in Kuwait
that needs to span these disciplines and
length scales
um and so you know uh
work in the project today work in CBA
today ranges from
developing zeptidual electronics for the
lowest power Computing to micro
Machining Diamond to take million 10
million RPM bearings for molecular
spectroscopy studies up to exploring
robots to build 100 meter structures in
space
okay can we the three things you just
mentioned let's start with the biggest
what are some of the biggest stuff you
attempted to explore how to build in a
lab sure so viewed from One Direction
what we're talking about is a crazy
random seeming of almost unrelated
projects but if you rotate 90 degrees
it's really just a core thought over and
over again just very literally how bits
and atoms relate how digital and just
going from digital to physical in many
different domains but it's really just
the same idea over and over again
so to understand the biggest things
let me go back to uh bring in now
Shannon as well as Von Neumann yeah so
what is digital
the Casual obvious answer is digital in
one and zero but that's wrong there's a
much deeper answer which is
Claude Shannon at MIT wrote the best
Master's thesis ever in his master's
thesis he invented our modern notion of
digital logic
where it came from was Van ever Bush uh
was a grand old man at MIT uh he created
the post-war research establishment that
led to the National Science Foundation
and he made an important mistake which
we can talk about
but he also made the let the
differential analyzer which was the last
great analog computer so it was a room
full of gears and pulleys and the longer
it ran the worse the answer was
and Shannon worked on it as a student
and he got so annoyed in his master's
thesis he invented digital logic
um but he then went on to Bell labs and
what he did there was
communication was beginning to expand
there is more demand for phone lines and
so there's a question about how much how
many phone lines you could phone
messages you could send down a wire
and you could try to just make it better
and better he asked a question nobody
had asked which is rather than make it
better and better what's the limit to
how good it can be and he proved a
couple things but one of the main things
he proved was a threshold theorem for
channel capacity and so what he showed
was my voice to you right now is coming
as a wave through sound and the further
you get the worse it sounds but people
watching this are getting it as as in
from packets of data in a network
um when they get when the computer
they're watching this gets the packet of
information
um it it can detect and correct an error
and what Shannon showed is if the noise
in in the cable to the people watching
this is above a threshold they're doomed
but if the noise is below a threshold
for a linear increase in the energy
representing our conversation the error
rate goes down exponentially
exponentials are fast there's very few
of them in engineering and the
exponential reduction of error below a
threshold if you restore state is called
a threshold theorem
that's what led to digital that that
means unreliable things can work
reliably so Shannon did that for
communication then van Neumann was
inspired by that and applied it to
computation and he showed how an
unreliable computer can operate reliably
by using the same threshold property of
restoring state it was then forgotten
many years we had to ReDiscover it in
effect in the quantum Computing era when
things are very unreliable again
but now to go back to how does this
relate to the biggest things I've made
so
in fabrication MIT
invented computer-controlled
Manufacturing in 1952 jet aircraft were
just emerging there is a limit to
Turning cranks on a machine on a milling
machine to make parts for jet aircraft
now this is a messy story MIT actually
stole computer controlled Machining from
an inventor who brought it to MIT wanted
to do a joint project with the Air Force
and MIT effectively stole it from him so
it's kind of a messy history but
that sounds like the birth of
computer-controlled Machining 1952.
there are a number of inventors of 3D
printing one of the companies spun off
my lab by Max lebowsky's form Labs which
is now a billion dollar 3D printing
company that's the modern version
but all of that's analog meaning the
information is in the control computer
there's no information in the materials
and so it goes back to Van ever Bush's
analog computer if you mistake make a
mistake in printing or Machining just
the mistake accumulates
the real birth of computerized digital
manufacturing is four billion years ago
that's the evolutionary age of the
ribosome
so the way you're manufactured is
there's a code that describes you
the genetic code it goes to a micro
machine the ribosome which is this
molecular Factory that builds the
molecules that that are you
the key thing to know about that is it
there are about 20 amino acids that get
assembled and in that Machinery it does
everything Shannon and vanyman taught us
you detect and correct errors so if you
mix chemicals the error rate is about a
part in a hundred
when you make elongate a protein in the
ribosome it's about a part in 10 to the
four when you replicate DNA there's an
extra level of error correction it's a
part in 10 to the eight and so in the
molecules that make you
you can detect and correct errors and
you don't need a ruler to make you the
geometry comes from your parts
so now
compare a child playing with Lego and a
state-of-the-art 3D printer or
computerized milling machine
the Tower made by a child is more
accurate than their motor control
because the act of snapping the bricks
together gives you a constraint on the
joints
you can join bricks made out of
dissimilar materials you don't need a
ruler for Lego because the geometry
locally gives you the global parts and
there's no Lego trash the parts have
enough information to disassemble them
those are exactly the properties of a
digital code the unreliable is made
reliable yes absolutely so what the
ribosome figured out four billion years
ago is how to embody these problems
these digital properties but not for
communication or computation in effect
but for construction
so a number of projects in my lab have
been studying the idea of digital
materials and think of a digital
material just as Lego bricks the precise
meaning is a degree discrete set of
Parts reversibly joined
um with global geometry determined from
local constraints and so it's digitizing
the materials and so I'm coming back to
what are the biggest things I've made my
lab was working with the Aerospace
industry so Spirit era was Boeing's
factories
they asked us for how to join Composites
when you make a composite airplane you
make these giant wing and fuselage parts
and they asked us for a better way to
stick them together because the joints
were a place of failure and what we
discovered was instead of making a few
big Parts if you make little Loops of
carbon fiber
and you reversibly link them in joints
and you do it in a special geometry that
balances being under constrained and
over constrained with just the right
degrees of freedom we set the world
record for the highest modulus
ultralight material just by if in effect
making carbon fiber Lego
so so lightweight materials are crucial
for Energy Efficiency this let us make
that the lightest weight High modulus
material we then showed that with just
just a few part types we can tune the
material properties and then you can
create really wild robots that instead
of having a tool the size of a jumbo jet
to make a jumbo jet you can make little
robots that walk on these cellular
structures to build the structures where
they error correct their position on the
structure and they navigate on the
structure and so using all of that with
um NASA we made more airplanes a former
student Kenny
Chung and benjinette made a morphing
airplane the size of NASA Langley's
biggest wind tunnel with Toyota we've
made super efficiency race cars we're
right now looking at projects with NASA
to build these for things like space
telescopes and space habitats where the
ribosome who I mentioned a little while
back can make an elephant one molecule
at a time ribosomes are slow they run at
about one molecule a second but
ribosomes make ribosomes so you have
thousands of them trillions of them and
that makes an elephant in the same way
these little assembly robots I'm
describing can make giant structures
uh at heart because of the robot can
make the robot so more recently to my
students Amira and Miana had a nature
communication paper showing how this
robot can be made out of the parts it's
making so the robots can make the robots
so you build up the capacity of robotic
assembly you can self-replicate can you
Linger on what that robot looks like
what is a robot it can walk along and do
error correction and what is a robot
that can self-replicate uh from the
materials that is given what does that
look like what are we talking so um this
is fascinating yeah the answer is
different at different length scales so
so to explain that in biology primary
structure is the code in the messenger
RNA that says what the ribosome should
build yeah
um secondary structure or geometrical
motifs they're things like helices or
sheets tertiary structures are
functional elements like electron donors
or acceptors quaternary structure is
things like molecular Motors that are
moving my mouth or making the synapses
work in my brain so there's that
hierarchy of primary secondary tertiary
quaternary
now what's interesting is
if you want to buy Electronics today
from a vendor there are hundreds of
thousands of types of resistors or
capacitors or transistors huge inventory
all of biology is just made from this
inventory of 20 Parts amino acids and by
composing them you can create all of
life
and so
as part of this digitization of
materials
we're in effect trying to create
something like amino acids for
engineering creating all of Technology
from 20 Parts I
um I see as another discretion I helped
start an office for science in Hollywood
and
um there was a fun thing for the movie
The Martian where I did a program with
Bill Nye and a few others on how to
actually build a civilization on Mars
that they described in a way that I like
as I was talking about how to go to Mars
without luggage and the at heart it's
sort of how to create life in non-living
materials so if if you think about this
primary secondary tertiary quaternary
structure
um in my lab we're doing that but on
different length scales for different
purposes so we're making micro robots
out of like Nano bricks and to make the
robots to build large-scale structures
in Space the elements of the robots now
are centimeters rather than micrometers
and so the assembly robots for the
bigger structures are
uh there are the cells that make up the
structure but then we have functional
cells and so cells that can process and
actuate each cell can like move one
degree of Freedom or attach or disk
detach or process now those elements I
just described we can make out of the
still smaller parts So eventually
there's the hierarchy of the little
Parts make little robots that make
bigger parts of bigger robots that up
through that hierarchy in that way you
can move up the line scale right early
on I tried to go in a straight line from
the bottom to the top and that ended up
being a bad idea instead we're kind of
doing all of these in parallel and then
they're growing together and so to make
the larger scale structures we um like
there's a lot of a hype right now about
3D printing houses where you have a
printer the size of the house we're
right now working on using swarms of
these you know table scale robots that
walk on the structures to place the
parts much more efficiently that's
amazing but you're saying you can't for
now go from the very small to the very
large that'll come
um that'll come in stages can we just
Linger on this idea starting from
vinelman's uh self-replicating automata
that you mentioned
it's just a beautiful idea so that's at
the heart of all of this in the stack I
described so one student will Langford
made these micro robots out of little
parts that then we're using for miana's
bigger robots up through this hierarchy
and it's really realizing this idea of
the self-reproducing automata so van
Neumann when I complained about the
weinerman architecture it's not fair
Devon Neumann because he never claimed
it as his architecture he really wrote
about it in this one fairly Dreadful
memo that led to all sorts of lawsuits
and fights and about the early days of
computing he did beautiful work on
reliable computation and unreliable
devices and towards the end of his life
what he studied was how and I have to
say this precisely how a computation
communicates its own construction
so beautiful so a computation can store
a description of how to build itself but
now there's a really hard problem which
is
how if you have that in your mind how do
you transfer it and wake up a thing that
then can contain it
um so how do you give birth to a thing
that knows how to make itself and so um
with Stan ulam he invented cellular
automata as a way to simulate these uh
but that was theoretical now the work
I'm describing in my lab is is
fundamentally how to realize it how to
re um realize self-reproducing uh
automata and so you know this is
something van Neumann thought very
deeply and very beautiful of beautifully
about theoretically and it's right at
this intersection it it's not
communication or computation or
fabrication
it's right at this intersection where
communication and computation meets
fabrication
now the reason self-reproducing automata
intellectually is so important because
this is the foundation of life this is
really just understanding the essence of
how to life and in effect we're trying
to create life and non-living material
the reason it's so important
technologically is because that's how
you scale capacity that's how you can
make an elephant from a ribosome because
the assemblers make assemblers so simple
building blocks yeah that inside
themselves contain the information how
to build more building blocks and so uh
between each other construct arbitrarily
complex objects right now let me give
you the numbers so let me relate this to
right now we're living in AI Mania
explosion time
let me relate that to what we're talking
about
a hundred petaflop computer
which is a current generation uh
supercomputer not quite the biggest ones
does 10 to the 17 Ops per second
your brain does 10 to the 17 Ops per
second it has about 10 to the 15
synapses and they run at about 100 Hertz
so as of a year or two ago
the compute the performance of a big
computer matched a brain so you could
view AI as a breakthrough but the real
story is
um within about a year or two ago and
let's see that that the super computer
has about 10 to the 15 transistors in
the processors 10 to the 15 transistors
in the memory which is the synapses in
your brain so the real breakthrough was
the computers match the computational
capacity of a brain and so we'd be sort
of derelict if they couldn't do about
the same thing but now the reason I'm
mentioning that is
the
chip Fab making the supercomputer is
placing about 10 to the 10 transistors a
second
while you're digesting your lunch right
now you're make you're placing about 10
to the 18 parts per second
um there's an eight order of magnitude
difference not so in computational
capacity it's done we've caught up
but there's eight orders of magnitude
difference in the rate at which biology
can build versus state-of-the-art
manufacturing can build
and that distinction is what we're
talking about that distinction is not
analog but this deep sense of digital
fabrication of embodying codes in
construction so a description doesn't
describe a thing but the description
becomes the thing so you're saying I
mean this is one of the cases you're
making and that this is this third
Revolution we've seen the Moore's law in
communication we've seen the Moore's Law
like type of growth in uh computation
and you're anticipating we're going to
see that in digital fabrication can you
actually first of all describe what you
mean by this term digital fabrication so
the Casual meaning is the computer
controls the tool to make something and
that was invented when MIT stole it in
1952. yeah um there's the deep meaning
of what the ribosome does of a
computation of a dis a digital
description doesn't describe a thing a
digital description becomes the thing
yeah that's where the that's that's the
path to the Star Trek replicator
and that's the thing that doesn't exist
yet
now I think the the best way to
understand what this roadmap looks like
is to now bring in Fab labs and how they
relate to all of this what are Fab Labs
so here here's a sequence
um with colleagues I accidentally
started a network of what's now 2500
digital fabrication Community Labs
called Fab Labs right now in 125
countries and they double every year and
a half that's called lassa's law after
Sherry Lasseter who I'll explain so
here's the sequence
uh we started Center for bits and atoms
to do the kind of research we're talking
about we had all of these machines and
then had a problem it would take a
lifetime of classes to learn to use all
the machines
so with
you know colleagues who helped start CBA
we began a class modestly called how to
make almost anything yeah and there's no
big agenda it was just it was aimed at a
few research students to use the
machines and it were completely
unprepared for the first time we taught
it we were swamped by every year since
hundreds of students try to take the
class it's one of the most over
subscribed classes at MIT
um students would say things like can
you teach this at MIT it seems too
useful it's just how to work these
machines and the students in the class I
would teach them all the skills to use
all these tools and then they would do
projects integrating them and they were
amazing so Kelly was a sculptor no
engineering background uh her project
was she made a device that saves up
screams when you're mad and placed them
back later
and saves up screams when you're mad and
plays them back later you scream into
this device and it it it deadens The
Sound records it and then when it's
convenient releases your screen can we
just just like pause on the Brilliance
of that invention creation the art
I don't know the Brilliance who is this
that created Kelly Dobson going on to do
a number of interesting things uh me Jin
who's gone on to do a number of
interesting things uh made a dress
instrumented with sensors and spines and
when somebody creepy comes close it
would defend your personal space they're
also very easy um another project early
on was a web browser for parrots which
have the cognitive ability of a young
child and lets parrots surf the Internet
an alarm clock you wrestle with and
prove you're awake and what connects all
of these is
so MIT made the first real-time computer
the Whirlwind that was transistorized as
the TX the TX was spun off from MIT as
the PDP pdp's
where the mini computers that created
the internet
so outside MIT was deck Prime Wang data
General the whole mini computer industry
the whole Computing industry was there
and it all failed when Computing became
personal
Ken Olsen the head of digital famously
said you don't need a computer at home
there's a little background to that but
but deck you know completely missed
Computing became personal so I mentioned
all of that because
I was asking how to do digital
fabrication but not really why the
students in this how to make class were
showing me that the killer app of
digital fabrication is personal
fabrication yeah how do you jump to the
personal fabrication so Kelly didn't
make the screen body because it was for
a thesis she wasn't writing a research
paper it wasn't a business model she
wanted it was because she wanted one
yeah it was personal expression going
back to me and vocational schools
personal expression in these new means
of expression so that's happened every
year since it literally is called the
course is literally called how to make
almost anything yep a legendary course
at MIT yep yep every year
um and it's grown to multiple Labs
um at MIT with as many people involved
in teaching is taking it and there's
even a Harvard lab for the MIT class
what what have you learned about humans
colliding with the Fab Lab about what
the capacity experience to be creative
and to build I I mentioned Marvin
another Mentor at MIT sadly no longer
living is Seymour pepper so pepper
studied with Piaget he came to MIT to
get access to the early compute Piaget
was a Pioneer in how kids learn
um papert came to MIT to get access to
the early computers with the goal of
letting kids play with them Piaget
helped show kids are like scientists
they they learn as scientists and it
gets kind of throttled out of them
Seymour wanted to let kids have a
broader landscape to play Seymour's work
LED with Mitch Resnick to Lego logo
Mindstorms all of that stuff as Fab Lab
spread and we started creating
educational programs for kids in them
Seymour said something really
interesting he made a gesture he said it
was a thorn in his side
that they invented What's called the
turtle a robot kids could early robot
kids could program to connect it to a
Mainframe computer Seymour said
the goal was not for the kids to program
the robot it was for the kids to create
the robot
and so in that sense the Fab Labs which
for me were just this accident he
described as sort of this fulfillment of
the Arc of kids learn by experimenting
it was to give them the tools to create
not just assemble things and program
things but actually create so come into
your question
what I've learned
is
MIT a few years back somebody added
added up businesses from spun off from
MIT and it's the world's 10th economy it
falls between India and Russia and I
view that in a way as a bad number
because it's only a few thousand people
and these aren't uniquely the four
thousand brightest people it's just a
productive environment for them and what
we found is in rural Indian villages in
African Shanty towns and Arctic
um Hamlet I find exactly precisely that
profile so
um link cited a few hours above Trump so
way above the Arctic circles it's so far
north the satellite dishes look at the
ground not the sky
um Hans Christian in the lab was
considered a problem in the local school
because they couldn't teach him anything
I showed him a few projects next time I
came back he was designing and building
Little Robot vehicles and in
um South Africa in I mentioned social
Govi in this apartheid Township the
local Technical Institute taught kids
how to make bricks and fold sheets it
was it was punitive but to piso in the
Fab Lab was actually doing all the work
of my MIT classes and so over and over
we found precisely the same kind of
bright invent of
um creativity
uh and historically the answer was
go you're smart go away it's sort of
like me and vocational school but in
this lab Network what we could then do
is in effect bring the world to them now
let's look at the scaling of all of this
so there's one Earth a thousand cities a
million towns a billion people a
trillion things
there was one Whirlwind computer and my
teammate uh the first real-time computer
there were thousands of pdps there were
millions of hobbyist computers that came
from that billions of personal computers
trillions of Internet of things so now
if we look at this Fab Lab story 1952
was the NC Mill
there are now thousands of Fab labs and
the Fab Lab costs exactly the same cost
and complexity of the mini computer so
on the mini computer it it didn't fit in
your pocket it filled a room but video
games email word processing really
anything you do with the internet
anything you do with a computer today
happened at that era because it got on
the scale of a work group not a
corporation
in the same way Fab labs are like the
mini computers inventing how does the
world work if anybody can make anything
then if you look at that scaling
Fab Labs today are transitioning from
buying a machine to make machines making
machines so we're transitioning to you
can go to a Fab Lab not to make a
project to make but to make a new
machine
so we talked about the Deep sense of
self-replication there's a very
practical sense of Fab Lab machines
making Fab Lab machines
and so that's the equivalent of the uh
hobbyist computer era what it's called
the Altair historically then the work we
spent a while talking about about
assemblers and self-assemblers that's
the equivalent of smartphones and
internet of things that's when so the
the assemblers are like the smartphone
where a smartphone today has the
capacity of what used to be a
supercomputer in your pocket and then
the smart thermostat on your wall has
the power of the original PDP computer
not metaphorically but literally and now
there's trillions of those in the same
sense that when we finally merge
materials with the machines in the
self-assembly that's like the Internet
of Things stage but here's the important
lesson
if you look at the Computing analogy
Computing expanded exponentially but it
really didn't fundamentally change the
the core things happened in in that
transition in the mini computer era so
in the same sense the research now I'm
we spent a while talking about is how we
get to the replicator
today you can do all of that if you
close your eyes and view the whole Fab
Lab as a machine in that room you can
make almost anything but you need a lot
of inputs bit by bit the inputs will go
down and the size of the room will go
down as we go through each of these
stages
so how difficult is it to create a
self-replicating assembler
self-replicating machine that builds
copies of itself or builds more
complicated version of itself which is
kind of the dream towards which you're
pushing in a generic arbitrary sense I
had a student Nadia Peak with Jonathan
Ward who who for me started this idea of
how do we use the tools in my lab to
make the tools in the lab yes in a very
clear sense they are making
self-reproducing machines so one of the
really cool things that's happened is
there's a whole network of machine
Builders around the world so there's
Danielle and now in Germany and yens in
Norway and
um each of these people is has learned
the skills to go into a Fab Lab and make
a machine and so we've started creating
a network of superfap so the Fab Lab can
make a machine but it can't make a
number of the Precision parts of the
machine so in places like Bhutan or
Carol in the south of India we started
creating super Fab Labs that have more
advanced tools to make the parts of the
machines so that the machines themselves
become even cheaper
so
that that is self-reproducing machines
but you need to feed it things like
bearings or microcontrollers they can't
make those parts but other than that
they're making their own things and I
should note as a footnote the stack I
described of computers controlling
machines to machine making machines to
assemblers to self-assemblers view that
as fab1234
so we're transitioning from fab 1 to Fab
two and the research in the lab is three
and four at this Fab two stage a big
component of this is uh sustainability
in the material feedstocks so Alicia
colleague in Chile is leading a great
effort looking at how you take Forest
Products and coffee grounds and
seashells and a range of locally
available materials and produce the
high-tech materials that go into the lab
so all of that is machine building today
then
back in the lab what we can do today is
we have robots that can build structures
and can assemble more robots that build
structures
we have finer resolution robots that can
build micro mechanical systems so robots
that can build robots that can walk and
manipulate and we're just now we have a
project
at the layer below that where there's
endless attention today to billion
dollar chip Fab Investments uh but a
really interesting thing we passed
through is today the smallest
transistors you can buy as a single
transistor just commercially for
electronics is actually the size of an
early transistor in an integrated
circuit
so we're using these machines making
machines making assemblers to place
those parts to not use a billion dollar
chip Fab to make integrated circuits but
actually assemble little electronic
components so I have a fine enough
precise enough actuators and
manipulators that allow you to place
these transistors right that's a
research project in my lab
on called dice on discrete assembly of
integrated electronics and we're just at
the point to really start to take
seriously this notion of not having a
chip Fab make integrated Electronics but
having not a 3D printer but a thing
that's a cross between a pick and place
makes circuit boards in 2D the 3D
printer extrudes in 3D we're making sort
of a micro manipulator that acts like a
printer but it's placing to build
Electronics in 3D but this micro
manipulator is distributed so there's a
bunch of them or is this one centralized
thing so that's why that's a great
question so um I have a prize that's
almost but not been claimed for the
students whose thesis can walk out of
the printer oh nice so you have to print
the thesis
with the means to to exit the printer
and it has to contain its description of
the thesis that says how to do that
it's a really good uh I mean it's a it's
a it's a fun example of exactly the
thing we're talking about and I've had a
few students almost
get to that
um and so
um in what I'm describing there's this
stack where we're getting closer but
it's still quite a few years to really
go from us so there's a layer below the
transistors where we assemble the base
materials that become the transistor
we're now just at the edge of assembling
the transistors to make the circuits
we can assemble the micro parts to make
the micro robots we can assemble the
bigger robots and in the coming years
we'll be patching together all of those
uh scales so do you see a vision of just
endless billions of robots at the
different scales self-assembling uh
self-replicating and building the
complicated structures yes
yes and the butt to the yes but is let
me clarify two things one is that
immediately
raises King Charles fear of gray goo of
runaway mutant self-reproducing things
the reason why there are many things I
can tell you to worry about but that's
not one of them
is if you want things to autonomously
self-reproduce and take over the world
that means they need to compete with
nature on using the resources of nature
of water and sunlight and in light of
everything I'm describing biology knows
everything I told you every single thing
I explain biology already knows how to
do
um uh what I'm describing isn't new for
biology it's new for non-biological
systems so in the digital era the
economic win ended up being centralized
the big platforms
in this world of machines that can make
machines I'm I'm asked for example
um you know what what's the killer
opportunity you know who's going to make
all the money
um who to invest in but if the machine
can make the machine it's not a great
business to invest in the machine
um in the same way that if you can
produce if you can think globally but
produce locally then the way the
technology goes out into society isn't a
function of central control but is
fundamentally distributed now that
raises an obvious kind of concern which
is well doesn't this mean you could make
bombs and guns and all of that
the reason that's much less of a problem
than you would think is making bombs and
guns and all of that is a very well met
Market need anywhere we go there's a
fine supply chain for weapons now
hobbyists have been making guns for ages
and guns are available just about
anywhere so you could go into the lab
and make a gun today it's not a very
good gun and guns are easily available
and so generally we run these lab in war
zones what we find is
people don't go to them to make weapons
which you can already do anyway it's an
alternative to making weapons it coming
back to your question I'd say the single
most important thing I've learned is
the greatest natural resource of the
planet is this amazing density of
Brighton event of people whose brains
are underused and
um you could view the the social
engineering of this lab work as creating
the capacity for them and so it you know
in the end the way this is going to
impact Society isn't going to be command
and control it's how the world uses it
and it's been really gratifying for me
to see just how it does yeah but what
are the different ways uh the evolution
of the exponential scaling of digital
fabrication can evolve so you said uh
yeah self-replicating Nanobots right
this is the the gray goo
fear it's the caricature of a fear but
nevertheless there's interesting just
like you said spam and all these kinds
of things that came with the scaling of
communication and computation what are
the different ways that malevolent
actors will use this technology yeah
well first let me start with a
benevolent story which is
uh trash is an analog concept there's no
trash in a forest all the parts get
disassembled and reused trash means
something doesn't have enough
information to tell you how to reuse it
yeah it's as simple as there's no trash
in a Lego room
when you assemble Lego the Lego bricks
have enough information to disassemble
them so one of the so as you go through
this Fab one two three four story one of
the implications of this transition to
from printing to assembling so the real
breakthrough technologically isn't
additive versus subtractive which is the
subject of a lot of attention and hype
um yep 3D printers are useful
um you know we spun off companies like
form Labs led by Max for 3D printing but
in a Fab Lab it's one of maybe 10
machines it's it's used but it's only
part of the machines the real
technological change is when we go from
Printing and cutting to assembling uh
and disassembling but that reduces
inventories of hundreds of thousands of
parts to just having a few parts to make
almost anything it reduces Global Supply
chains to locally sourcing these
building blocks but one of the key
implications is it gets rid of
technological trash
because you can disassemble and reuse
the parts not throw them away and so
initially that's of interest for things
at the end of long Supply chains Like
Satellites on orbit but one of the
things coming is eliminating technical
trash through reuse of the building
blocks so like when you think about 3D
printers you're thinking about solution
and subtraction
when you think about the other options
available to you in that parameter space
as you call it that's going to be
assembly disassembly cutting you said so
the 1952 NC Mill was subtractive you
remove material and 3D printing additive
and there's a couple claims to the
invention of 3D printing that's closer
to what's called net shape which is you
don't have to cut away the material you
don't need you just put material where
you do need it and so that's the 3D
printing Revolution but
there are all sorts of limitations on 3D
printing to the kinds of materials you
can print the kind of functionality you
can print we're just not going to get to
making a
um everything in a cell phone on a
single printer but I do expect to make
everything in a cell phone with an
assembler and so instead of printing and
cutting technologically it's this
transition to assembling and
disassembling it going back to Shannon
and Von Neumann going back to the
ribosome for a billion years ago
now you come to malevolent
um let me tell you a story about
I was
doing a briefing for the National
Academy of Sciences group that advises
the intelligence communities
and I talked about the kind of research
we do
and at the very end I showed a little
video clip of Valentina and Ghana
um making a local girl making surface
mount Electronics in the Fab Lab and I
showed that to this room full of people
uh one of the members of the
intelligence Community got up livid and
said how dare you waste our time showing
us a young girl in an African village
making service non-electronics we're
looking at we need to know about
disruptive threats to the future of the
United States
and somebody else got up in the room and
yelled at him and you idiot I can't
think of anything more important than
this yeah but for two reasons one reason
was
um because if we rely on like
informational superiority in the
battlefield it means other people could
get access to it but this intelligence
person's point bless him wasn't that it
was
getting at the root causes of conflict
is if this young girl in an African
village could actually Master surface
mount Electronics it changes some of the
most fundamental things about
recruitment for terrorism
um uh impact of economic migration basic
assumptions about an economy it's just
existential for the future of the planet
but you know we've just lived through a
pandemic
I would love to linger on this because
the possibilities that are positive are
endless yeah but the possibility is a
negative are still nevertheless
extremely important was both positive
and negative what do you do
with a large number of General
assemblers yeah with the Fab Lab you
could roughly make a bio lab then learn
biotechnology now that's terrifying
because making self-reproducing gray goo
that out competes biology I consider
Doom because biology knows everything
I'm describing and is really good at
what it does
um
in
how to grow almost anything you learn
skills in biotechnology that would let
that let you make serious biological
threats and when you combine
uh some of the Innovations you see with
large language models some of the
Innovations you see with Alpha fold so
applications of AI for Designing
biological systems for uh writing
programs which you can large language
models increasingly so there seems to be
an interesting dance here of automating
the design stage of complex systems
using Ai and then that's the that's the
bits and you can leap now the
Innovations you're talking about you can
leap from the complex systems in the
digital space to the printing to the
creation to the assembly
at scale
of uh complex systems in the physical
space yeah so something to be scared
about is
a Fab Lab can make a bio lab a bio lab
can make biotechnology somebody could
learn to make a virus that's scary that
that's unlike some of the things I said
I don't worry about that's something I
really worry about that is scary now how
do you deal with that uh
prior threats we dealt with
command and control
so like uh
early color copiers had unique codes and
you could tell which copier made them
eventually you couldn't keep up with
that uh there there was a famous meeting
at asilamar in the early days of
recombinant DNA where that Community
recognized the dangers of what it was
doing and put in place a regime to help
manage it and so that led to the kind of
research management so you know MIT has
an office that supervises research and
it works with the national office that
works if you can identify who's doing it
and where it doesn't work in this world
we're describing
so anybody could do this anywhere and so
what we found is you can't
contain this it's already L you can't
forbid because there isn't command and
control the most useful thing you can do
is provide incentives for transparency
yes so but really the heart of what we
do is you could do this by yourself in a
basement for nefarious reasons or you
could come into a place in the light
where you get help and you get community
and you get resources and there's an
incentive to do it in the open not in
the dark and that might sound naive but
in the sort of places we're working oh
you know
um again bad people do bad things in
these places already but providing
openness and providing transparency is a
key part of managing these and so it it
transitions from regulating risks as
regulation to to soft power to manage
them so there's so much potential for
good so much capacity for good that Fab
labs and the uh the the ability
um and the tools of creation really
unlock that potential
yeah and I don't say that as sort of
dewey-eyed naive I say that empirically
from just years of seeing how this plays
out in communities I wonder if it's the
early days of personal computers though
before we get spam right in the end most
fundamentally
literally the mother of all problems
is
who designed us so so assume
success and that we're going to
transition to the machines making
machines and all of these new sort of
social systems we're describing will
help manage them and curate them and
democratize them
if we close the gap I just let off with
of 10 to the 10 to 10 to the 18 between
chip Fab and you
um we're ultimately in marrying
communication computation and
Fabrication going to be able to create
unimaginable complexity
um and how do you design that
and so I'd say
the deepest of all questions that I've
been working on
is
goes back to the oldest part of our
genome so
in our genome what are called Hox genes
and these are morphogenes
and
nowhere in your genome is the number
five it doesn't store the fact that you
have five fingers
um what it stores is What's called the
developmental program it's a series of
steps and the steps have the character
of like grow up a gradient or break
symmetry
and at the end of that developmental
program you have five fingers
so
you are stored not as a body plan
but as a growth Plan and there's two
reasons for that one reason is just
compression billions of genes can place
trillions of cells but the much deeper
one is evolution doesn't randomly
perturb almost anything you did randomly
in the genome would be fatal or
inconsequential but not interesting but
when you modify things in these
developmental programs you go from like
webs for swimming to fingers or you go
from walking to wings for flying it's a
space in which search is interesting so
this is the heart of the success of AI
in part it was the scaling we talked
about a while ago
and in part it was the representations
for which search is effective
AI has found good representations it
hasn't found new ways to search but it's
found good representations of search and
that's you're saying that's what biology
that's what evolution has done is
creative representation structures
biological structures through which
search effective and so the the
developmental programs in the genome
beautifully encapsulate the lessons of
AI and this is It's embody it's it's
molecular intelligence it's AI embodied
in our genome it it it it's every bit as
profound as the cognition in our brain
but now this is sort of thinking in
molecular thinking in how you design
and so
um I'd say the most fundamental problem
we're working on is it's kind of
tautological that when you design a
phone
you design the phone you represent the
design of the phone but that actually
fails when you get to the sort of
complexity that we're talking about and
so there's this profound transition to
come once I can have self-readressing
assemblers placing 10 to the 18 parts
um you need to not sort of
metaphorically but create life
in that you need to learn how to evolve
but evolutionary design has a really
misleading trivial meaning it's not as
simple as you randomly mutate things
it's this much more deep embodiment of
of AI and morphogenesis is there a way
for us to continue the kind of evolution
of design that led us to this place from
the early days of bacteria single cell
organisms to ribosomes and the 20 amino
acids you mean for human augmentation or
no for Life augment I mean what would
you call assemblers that are
self-replicating and placing Parts what
is that the the dynamic complex things
built with digital fabrication what is
that that's the light so yeah so
ultimately absolutely
if you add everything I'm talking about
it's building up to creating life in
non-living materials yes and I I don't
view this as copying life I view it as
driving life I I didn't start from how
does biology work and then I'm going to
copy it I start from how to solve
problems and then it it leads me to in a
sense ReDiscover biology so if we go
back to Valentina in Ghana making her
circuit board
um she still needs a chip Fab very far
away to make the processor under circuit
board for her to make the processor
locally for all the reasons we described
you actually need the Deep things we
were just talking about and so it really
does lead you so let's see there's a
wonderful series of books by gingery
book one is how to make a charcoal
furnace and at the end of book Seven you
have a machine shop
so it is it it's sort of how how you do
your own personal Industrial Revolution
uh isru is what NASA calls in-situ
resource utilization and that's how do
you go to a planet and create a
civilization uh isru has essentially
assumed gingery you go through the
Industrial Revolution and you create the
inventory of a hundred thousand
resistors what we're finding is the way
you the minimum building blocks for a
civilization is
roughly 20 parts so what's interesting
about the amino acids is they're not
interesting they're hydrophobic or
hydrophilic basic or acidic they have
typical but not extremal properties but
they're good enough you can combine them
to make you
so what this is leading towards is
technology doesn't need enormous Global
Supply chains it just needs about 20
properties you can compose to create all
technology as the minimum building
blocks for a technological civilization
so there's going to be 20 basic building
blocks based on which the
self-replicating assemblers can work
right and I say that not philosophically
just empirically sort of that's that
that's where it's heading and
yeah that I like thinking about how you
bootstrap a civilization on Mars that
problem there's a fun video on bonus
material for the movie where where with
a neat group of people we talk about it
because it has really profound
implications back here on Earth about
how we live sustainably
what is that Civilization on Mars looks
like that's using a isru that's using
these 20 building blocks and does
self-assembly yeah go go through primary
secondary tertiary quaternary
um you know you you extract properties
like uh conducting insulating
semiconducting uh magnetic uh dielectric
flexural these are the kind of you know
roughly 20 properties
um with those
those are enough for us to assemble
logic
and they're enough for us to assemble
actuation
um with logic and actuation we can make
micro robots
the micro robots can build bigger robots
um the bigger robots can then take the
building block materials and make the
structural elements that you then do to
make construction and then you boot up
through the stages of a technological
Civilization by the way where in the
span of logic and actuation to the
sensing come in oh I skipped over that
but my favorite sensor is a step
response so if you just make a step and
measure the response to the electric
field
that ranges from user interfaces to
positioning to material properties and
if you do it at higher frequencies you
get chemistry and you can get all of
that just from a step in an electric
field so for example once you have time
resolution in logic something as simple
as two elect roads let you do amazingly
capable sensing so we've been talking
about all the work I do there's a story
about
how it happens you know where do ideas
come from and that's an interesting
story where do I just come from so I had
mentioned veniver Bush and
uh he wrote a really influential thing
called the endless Frontier so uh
science won World War II the the the the
more known story is nuclear bombs the
less well-known story is the rad lab so
at MIT an amazing group of people
invented radar which is really credited
as winning the war so after the war uh
grand old man from MIT and it's a
um uh was charged with science won the
war how do we maintain that edge and the
report he wrote led to the National
Science Foundation and the modern notion
we take for granted but didn't really
exist before then of Public Funding of
research or research agencies
in it he made again what I consider an
important mistake which is he described
basic research leads to applied research
search leads to Applications leads to
commercialization leads to impact and so
we need to invest in that pipeline
the reason I considered a mistake
is almost all of the examples we've been
talking about
in my lab went backwards that the basic
research came from applications
and further almost all of the examples
we've been talking about came
fundamentally from mistakes so yeah
essentially everything I've ever worked
on has failed
but in failing something better happened
so the way I like to describe it is
ready aim fire is you do your homework
um you aim carefully at something a
Target you want to accomplish and if
everything goes right you then hit the
target and succeed
um what I do you can think of is ready
fire Aim so you you do a lot of work to
get ready
then you close your eyes and you don't
really think about where you're aiming
but you look very carefully at where you
didn't
you aim after you fire
and the the reason that's so important
is it if you do Ready Aim Fire there's
the best you can hope is hit what you
aim at so let me give you some examples
uh because this is a source of great
full of good lines today
source of great frustration so I
mentioned the early Quantum Computing so
Quantum Computing is this power of using
quantum mechanics to make computers that
for some problems are dramatically more
powerful than classical computers
before it started there was a really
interesting group of people who knew a
lot about
um physics and computing
that were inventing what became Quantum
Computing before it was clear anything
there was an opportunity there it was
just studying how those relate here's
how it fits to the ready fire aim in I
was doing really short-term work in my
lab on shoplifting tags
on this was really before there was
Modern RFID and so how you put tags in
objects to sense them
something we just take for granted
commercially and there was a problem of
how you can sense multiple objects at
the same time
and so I was studying how you can
remotely sense materials to make
low-cost tags that could let you
distinguish multiple objects
simultaneously to do that you need
non-linearity so that the signal is
modulated
and so I was looking for materials
sources of non-linearity and that led me
to look at how nuclear spins interact
just just for for
um spin resonance this is the sort of
things you use when you let go in an MRI
machine
and so I was studying how to use that
and it turns out that it was a bad idea
you couldn't remotely use it for
um shoplifting tags
but I realized you could compute and so
um with a group of colleagues thinking
about early Quantum Computing like David
divincenzo and Charlie Bennett was
articulating what are the properties you
need to compute and then looking at how
to make the tags it turns out the tags
were a terrible idea
for
um sensing
objects in a supermarket checkout but I
realized they were Computing so with Ike
Trang and a few other people we realized
we could program nuclear spins to
compute and so that's what we use to do
Grover's search algorithm and then it
was used for a shortest factoring
algorithm and it worked out the systems
we did it in nuclear magnetic resonance
don't scale Beyond a few qubits but the
techniques have lived on and so you know
all the current Quantum Computing
techniques grew out of the ways we would
talk to these spins but I'm telling this
whole story because it it came from a
bad way to make a shoplifting tag
starting with an application mistakes
led to the fundamental science
fundamental science yeah I mean can you
can you just link on that I mean just
just in using nuclear expensive do
computation that like
what gave you the guts to try to think
through this the from a fabric from a
digital fabrication perspective actually
how to LEAP from one to the other yeah I
wouldn't call it guts I would call it
collaboration so I so at IBM there was
this amazing group of like I mentioned
Charlie Bennett and David divincenzo and
Ralph Landau and Nabil Amir and these
were all gods of thinking about physics
and Computing so I I I I I yelled at the
whole computer industry being based on
uh a fiction Metropolis you know
programmers frolicking the garden while
somebody moves levers in the basement
there's a complete parallel history of
um uh Maxwell the boltzman to zillard to
um landower to Bennett and most people
won't know most of these names but this
whole parallel history thinking deeply
about how computation and physics relate
so
um I was collaborating with that whole
group of people
and then
you know at MIT I was in this high
traffic environment I wasn't deeply
inspired to think about better ways to
detect shoplifting tags but you know
stumbled across companies that needed
help with that and was thinking about it
and then I realized those two worlds
intersected and we could use the failed
approach for the shoplifting tags to
make
um early Quantum Computing algorithms
and this kind of stumbling is
fundamental to the Fab Lab idea right
right here's one more example with a
student Manu we talked about ribosomes
and I was trying to build a ribosome
um that worked on fluids so that I could
place the little Parts we're talking
about and we it kept failing because
bubbles would come into our system and
the bubbles would make the whole thing
stop working and we spent about half a
year trying to get rid of the bubbles
then Manu said wait a minute the bubbles
are actually
better than what we're doing we should
just use the bubbles and so we invented
how to do Universal object with little
logic with little Bubbles and fluid okay
you have to you have to explain this
microfluidic bubble logic please how
does this work so yeah that's super
interesting yeah and so over so I'll
come back and explain it but what it led
to was
um we showed fluids could do
um it had been known fluid could do
logic like your old automobile
transition Transmissions do logic but
that's macroscopic it didn't work at
little scales we showed with these
bubbles we could do it at little scales
that then I'm going to come back and
explain it but what came out of that is
Manu then showed you could make a 50
Cent microscope using little Bubbles and
then
um the techniques we developed are what
we use to transplant genomes to make
synthetic life all came out of the
failure of trying to make a the genome
the the the ribosome now so the way the
bubble logic works is
um in a little child Channel
uh fluid at small scales is fairly
viscous it's sort of like pushing Jello
think of it as
um
if a bubble gets stuck the fluid has to
detour around it
so now imagine
a channel that has two Wells and one
bubble
if the bubble is in one well the fluid
has to go in the other channel
if the fluid is in the other well it has
to go in the first channel
so the the position of the bubble
can switch
it's a switch it can switch the fluid
between two channels so now we have one
element of switch and it's also a memory
because you can detect whether or not a
bubble is stored there
then if two bubbles meet
um if you have two channels crossing a
bubble can go through one way or a
bubble can go through the other way but
if two bubbles come together then they
push on each other and one goes one way
and one goes the other way that's a
logic operation that's a logic gate so
we now have a switch we have a memory
and we have a logic eight and that's
everything you need to make a universal
computer
I mean the fact that you did that with
bubbles and microfluids just
kind of brilliant well so I mean to stay
with that example uh it it what we
propose to do was to make a fluidic
ribosome and the project crashed and
burned it was a disaster
um this is what came out of it and so it
was
precisely ready fire aim in that we had
to do a lot of homework to be able to
make these microfluidic systems
the the Fire part was we didn't think
too hard about making the ribosome we
just tried to do it the aim part was we
realized the ribosome failed but
something better had happened and if you
look all across research funding
research management
it doesn't
anticipate this so fail fast is familiar
but fail fast tends to miss ready and
aim you can't just fail you have to do
your homework before the fail part and
you have to do the aim part after the
fail part and so the whole language of
research is about like milestones and
deliverables that works when you're
going down a straight line but it
doesn't work for this kind of Discovery
and to LEAP to something you said that's
really important is I view part of what
the Fab Lab network is doing is giving
more people the opportunity to fail
you've said that geometry is really
important in biology
um
what is fabrication biology look like
why is geometry important so molecular
biology is dominated by geometry that's
why the protein folding is so important
that that that the geometry gives the
function
and
uh there's this hierarchical
construction of as you go through
primary second tertiary quaternary the
shapes of the molecules make the shape
of the molecular machines and they
really are Exquisite machines if you
look at how
um if you look at how your muscles move
if you were to see a simulation of it it
would look like a improbable science
fiction cyborg world of these little
walking robots that walk on a discrete
lattice they're really Exquisite
machines and and then from there this
this whole hierarchical stack of once
you get to the top of that you then
start making organelles that make cells
that make organs through the stack of
that hierarchy
just stepping back does it Amaze you
that from small building blocks where um
amino acids you mentioned molecules
let's go to the very beginning of
hydrogen and helium at the start of this
universe they were able to build up such
um
complex and beautiful things like our
human brain so studying thermodynamics
which is exactly the question of
you know that batteries run out and need
recharging
you know equipment
you know cars get old and fail yet life
doesn't and it that's why there's a
sense in which life seems to violate
thermodynamics although of course it
doesn't it seems to resist the March
towards entropy somehow right and so
Maxwell who helped give rise to the
science of thermodynamics uh posited a a
problem that was so infuriating it led
to a series of suicides there was a
series of
advisors and advisees
um three in a row that all ended up
committing suicide that happened to work
on this problem
and uh Maxwell's demon
is this simple but Infamous problem
where
right now in this room we're surrounded
by molecules and they run at different
velocities
um imagine a container that has a wall
and it's got gas on both sides and a
little door and if the door is a
molecular sized creature
and it could watch the molecules coming
and when a fast molecule is coming it
opens the door when a slow molecule is
coming it closes the door
after it does that for a while one side
is hot one is cold when something is hot
and is cold you can make an engine and
so you close that you make an engine and
you make energy
so the demon is violating thermodynamics
because it's it's not it's never
touching the molecule
yet by just opening and closing the door
it can make arbitrary amounts of energy
and power a machine and in
thermodynamics you can't do that so
that's Maxwell's demon
uh
that problem is connected to everything
we just spoke about for the last few
hours so uh Leo zillard
uh around
early 1900s was a deep physicist who
then had a lot to do with also
post-war anti-nuclear things but he
reduced Maxwell's demon to a single
molecule so the molecule one there's
only one molecule and the question is
which side of the partition is it on
that led to the idea of one bit of
information so Shannon credited
zillard's analysis of Maxwell's Neiman
for the invention of the bit
um for many years people tried to
explain Maxwell's demon by like the
energy in the demon looking at the
molecule
or the energy to open and close the door
and nothing ever made sense
finally Ralph landauer one of the
colleagues I mentioned at IBM
finally solve the problem
he showed that you can explain Maxwell's
demon
by you need the mind of the demon
when the demon opened and closes the
door as long as it remembers what it did
you can run the whole thing backwards
but when the demon forgets
then you can't run it backwards
and that's where you get dissipation and
that's where you get the violation of
thermodynamics and so the explanation of
Maxwell's demon is that it's it's in the
Demon's brain so then
Ross Khalid colleague Charlie at IBM
uh then shocked Ralph by showing you can
compute with arbitrarily low energy
so one of the things that's not well
covered is the the big computers used
for big machine learning the data
centers use tens of megawatts of power
they use as much power as a city
um Charlie showed you can actually
compute with arbitrarily low amounts of
energy
by making computers that can go
backwards as well as forwards
and what limits the speed of the
computer is
how fast you want an answer and how
certain you want the answer to be
but where orders of magnitude away from
that so I have a student Cameron working
with Lincoln Labs on making
superconducting computers that operate
near this land hour limit that are
orders of magnitude more efficient
um so stepping back to all of that that
whole tour was driven by your question
about life
and you know right at the heart of it is
Maxwell's demon life exists because it
can locally violate thermodynamics
they can locally violate thermodynamics
because of intelligence
and it's its molecular intelligence that
you know I would even go out on a limb
to say we can already see we're
beginning to come to the end of this
current AI phase so depending on how you
count this is I'd say the fifth AI boom
bust cycle
and you can already you know it it's
exploding but you can already see where
it's heading you know how it's going to
saturate what happens on the far side
um the big thing that's not yet on
Horizons is is
embodied AI molecular intelligence so to
step back to this AI story
um there was
Automation and that was going to change
everything then there were expert
systems
um uh there was then the you know the
first phase of the neural network
systems there's been about five of these
um in each case on the slope up it's
going to change everything
um in each case what happens is on the
slope down
um we sort of move the goal posts and it
becomes sort of irrelevant so a good
example is going up computer chess was
going to change everything once
computers could play chess that
fundamentally changes the world now on
the downside computers play chess
winning at chess is no longer seen as a
unique human thing but
um uh people still play chess this new
phase is going to take a new chunk of
things that we thought computers
couldn't do now computers will be able
to do they have roughly our brain
capacity
um but you know we'll keep thinking as
well as computers
um and as I described wow we've been
going through these five boom busts if
you just look at the numbers of Ops per
second bits storage bits of i o That's
the more interesting one that's been
steady and that's what finally caught up
to people but
you know as we've talked about a couple
times there's eight orders of magnitude
to go not in the intelligence and the
transistors or in the brain but in the
embodied intelligence in the
intelligence in our body so the
intelligent constructions of physical
systems that would embody the
intelligence versus container within the
computation right and there's a brain
centrism that assumes our intelligence
is centered in our brain
and in Endless ways in this conversation
we've been talking about molecular
intelligence our molecular systems do a
deep kind of artificial intelligence all
the things you think of as artificial
intelligence does in
representing knowledge storing knowledge
searching over knowledge adapting to
knowledge our molecular systems do
but the output isn't just a thought it's
it's us it's the evolution of us and
that's you know the real Horizon to come
is now embodying ai if not not just a
processor and a robot but but you know
Building Systems that really can
grow and evolve
so we've been speaking about this
boundary between bits and atoms so let
me ask you one of the about one of the
big mysteries of consciousness
do you think
it comes from somewhere between that
boundary I won't name names but if you
know who I'm talking about it's probably
clear I once did a drive in fact up up
to the mussoline era Villa outside
Torino
um in the early days of what became
Quantum computing
with
a a a famous person who thinks about
quantum mechanics and Consciousness and
we had the most infuriating conversation
that went roughly along the lines of
Consciousness is weird
quantum mechanics is weird therefore
quantum mechanics explains Consciousness
that was rough ly the The Logical
process
then you're not as satisfied with that
process no and I say that very precisely
in the following sense uh I was a
program manager somewhat by accident in
a DARPA program
on Quantum biology and so biology
trivially uses quantum mechanics and
that were made out of atoms but the
distinction is
in Quantum Computing Quantum information
you need Quantum coherence
and there's a lot of muddled thinking
about like
collapse of the wave function and claims
of quantum Computing that garbles just
Quantum coherence that
um that you can think of it as a wave
that has very special properties but
these wave like properties and so
there's a small set of places where
biology uses quantum mechanics in that
deeper sense one is how light is
converted to energy in photosystems
um it looks like one is olfaction how
your nose is able to tell different
smells
um probably one has to do with how birds
navigate
how they sense magnetic fields
that involves the coupling between a
very weak energy with a magnetic field
coupling into chemical reactions and
there's a beautiful system it
standard in chemistry is magnetic fields
like this can influence chemistry but
there are biological circuits that are
carefully balanced with two Pathways
that become unbalanced with magnetic
fields so each of these areas are
expensive for biology it has to consume
resources to use quantum mechanics in
this way
so again those are places where we know
there's quantum mechanics in biology in
cognition there's just no evidence there
there's uh there's no evidence of
anything quantum mechanical going on in
how cognition Works Consciousness well
I'm saying I'm saying cognition I'm not
saying Consciousness but to get from
cognition to consciousness
so McCullough and Pitts made a model of
neurons
um that led to perceptrons
that then threw a couple boom busts led
to deep learning one of the interesting
things about that sequence is it
diverged off so deep neural networks
used in machine learning diverged from
trying to understand how the brain works
um what what makes them work what's
emerged is they it's a really
interesting story this may be too much
of a technical detail but it has to do
with function approximation that that uh
we talked about exponentials a deep
Network
needs an exponentially larger shallow
Network to do the same function
and that that exponential is what gives
the power to deep networks but what's
interesting is the sort of lessons about
building these deep architectures and
how to train them
have really interesting Echoes to how
brains work
and there's an interesting conversation
that's sort of coming back of
neuroscientists looking over the
shoulder of people training these deep
networks seeing interesting Echoes for
how the brain works
interesting parallels with it and so I I
didn't say Consciousness I just said
cognition but
I don't know any experimental evidence
that points to anything in neurobiology
that says we need quantum mechanics
and
um I view the question about whether a
large language model is conscious as
silly in in that
biology is full of hacks
and it works
there's no evidence we have that there's
anything deeper going on than just this
sort of stacking up of hacks in the
brain and somehow Consciousness is one
of the hacks or an emergent property of
the hex absolutely and um just
numerically I said big computations now
have the degrees of freedom of the brain
and they're showing a lot of the
phenomenology of what we think as
properties of what a brain can do
um
and I don't see any reason to invoke
anything else that makes you wonder what
kind of beautiful stuff digital
fabrication will create if biology
created a few hacks on top of which
Consciousness and cognition some of the
things we love about human beings was
created it makes you wonder what kind of
Beauty in the complexity yeah it's a
digital family there's there's an early
peek at that which is
um there's a misleading term which is
generative design
generative design is where you don't
tell a computer how to design something
you tell the computer what you want it
to do that doesn't work that only works
in limited subdomains you can't do
really complex functionality that way
the one place that's matured though is
topology optimization for structure so
let's say you wanted to make a bicycle
or a table
you describe the loads on it and it
figures out how to design it and what it
makes are beautiful organic looking
things these are things that look like
they grew in a forest and
they look like they grew in a forest
because that's sort of exactly what they
are that they're they're they're solving
the ways of how you handle loads in the
same way biology does and so you get
things that look like trees and shells
and all of that and so that's a Peak at
this transition to
um from we we design to to we teach the
machines how to design what can you say
about because you mentioned cellular
automata earlier about from this example
you just gave and in general the
observation you can make by looking at
cellular automata that there's a
from simple rules and simple building
blocks can emerge arbitrary complexity
do we understand like do you understand
what that is how that can be leveraged
so understand what it is is much easier
than it sounds I complained about
turing's machine making a physics
mistake but Turing never intended it to
be a computer architecture he used it
just to prove uh results about
uncomputability
um what what Turing did on what his
computation is exquisite it's gorgeous
he gave us our notion of computational
universality and something that sounds
deep and turns out to be trivial is
it's really easy to show almost
everything is computationally universal
so Norm margulis wrote a beautiful paper
um with Tom tofully showing in a
cellular a cellular automata world is
like The Game of Life where you just
move tokens around
they showed that modeling billiard balls
on a billiard table with cellular
automata is a universal computer
to to be Universal you need a persistent
state
you need a non-linear operation to
interact them
um and you need connectivity
so that's what you need to show
computational universality so they
showed that a CA modeling billiard balls
is a universal computer
um Chris Moore went on to show that
instead of chaos let's see
um Turing showed there are computable
their problems in computation that you
can't solve
that they're harder than you can't
predict they're actually in a deep
reason they are unsolvable
um Chris Moore showed it's very easy to
make physical systems that are
uncomputable that what what the physics
system does
just bouncing balls and surfaces you can
make systems that solve uncomputable
problems and so almost any non-trivial
physical system is computationally
universal
so the first part of the answer to your
question is this comes back to how you
know my comment about how do you
bootstrap a civilization you just don't
need much to be computationally
Universal so then
that there isn't today a notion of like
fabricational universality or
fabricational complexity the sort of
numbers I've been giving you about you
eating lunch versus the chip Fab sort of
that that that's in the same Spirit of
what Shannon did but once you connect
computational
universality to kind of fabricational
universality you then get the ability to
grow and adapt and evolve
because that Evolution happens in the
physical space yeah and so that's why
you know for me the heart of this whole
conversation is morphogenesis so just to
come back to that
um
what touring
ended his sadly cut short life
studying
was how genes give rise to form so so
how the the the small amount of it
relatively in effect small amount of
information in the genome can give rise
to the complexity of Who You Are
and and that that that's where
what resides is this molecular
intelligence
which is first how to describe you but
then how to describe you such that you
can exist and you can reproduce and you
can grow and you can evolve
and so you know that that's the seat of
our molecular intelligence
the make a revolution in biology yeah it
really is
um it really is and and that that's
where you can't separate communication
computation and Fabrication you can't
separate computer science and physical
science you can't separate hardware and
software they all intersect right at
that place
do you think of our universe as just one
giant computation
I I would even kind of say Quantum
Computing is overhyped in that there's a
few things Quantum Computing is going to
be good at one is breaking crypto
systems but we know how to make new
crypto systems what it's really good at
is modeling other Quantum systems so for
studying
nanotechnology it's going to be powerful
but Quantum Computing is not going to
disrupt and change everything
but the reason I say that is this
interesting group of strange people who
helped invent Quantum Computing before
it was clear anything was there
one of the main reasons they did it
wasn't to make a computer that can break
a crypto system
it was you could turn this backwards you
could be surprised quantum mechanics can
compute
or you can go in the opposite opposite
direction and say if quantum mechanics
can compute
um that's a description of nature so
physics
is written in terms of partial
differential equations
that is an information technology
from uh two centuries ago
the the equations of physics are not
this would sound very strange to say but
the equations of physics Schrodinger's
equations and Maxwell's equations and
all of them are not fundamental they're
a representation of physics that was
accessible to us
in the era of having a pencil and a
piece of paper
they have a fundamental problem which is
if you make a DOT on a piece of paper in
traditional physics theory there's
information infinite information in that
dot a point
has infinite information
that can't be true because in
information is is
um a fundamental resource that's
connected to energy and in fact it
um one of my favorite questions you can
ask a cosmologist to trip them up is ask
is information a conserved quantity in
the universe
with all the information created in the
Big Bang or can the universe create
information and I've yet to meet a
cosmologist who doesn't stutter and
not clearly know how to handle that
existential question but sort of putting
that to a side
in physics theory the way it's taught
in information
comes late you know you're taught about
x a variable which can contain infinite
information but physically that's
unrealistic and so physics theories have
to find ways to cut that off
so instead
there are a number of people
Who start with
a theory of the universe should start
with information and computation as the
fundamental resources that explain
nature and then you build up from that
to something that looks like throwing
baseballs down a slope and so in that
sense
the work on physics and computation
has many applications that we've been
talking about but more deeply it's
really getting at new ways to think
about how the universe works and there
are a number of things that are hard to
do in traditional physics that make more
sense when you start with information
and computation as the root of physical
Theory so information and competition
being the the the real fundamental thing
in the universe right that information
is a resource you can't have you can't
have infinite information in finite
space
information propagates and interacts and
from there you erect the scaffolding of
physics now it happens
the words I just said look a lot like
Quantum field theories
but there's an interesting way where
instead of starting with different
differential equations to get to Quantum
field theories and Quantum field
theories you get to quantization
[Music]
um if you if if you start from
computation information you begin sort
of quantized and you build up from there
and so that's the sense in which uh
uh absolutely I think about the universe
as a computer the easy way to understand
that is
uh just almost anything is
computationally universal but the Deep
Way is it's a real fundamental way to
understand how the universe works
let me go a little bit to the personal
in the center bits and atoms
you have uh
uh worked with the students you've
worked with have gone on to do some
incredible things in this world
including build super computers that
power uh Facebook and Twitter and so on
what advice would you give to young
people what advice have you given them
how to have one heck of a great career
one heck of a great life what one
important one is
uh it if you look at Junior faculty
trying to get tenure at a place like MIT
the ones who try to figure out how to
get tenure or miserable and don't get
tenure and the ones who don't try to
figure it out are happy and do get it
yeah I mean you know you have to love
what you're doing and believe in it and
nothing else could possibly be what you
want to be doing with your life and it
gets you out of bed in the morning and
again it sounds naive but
um it within like The Limited domain I'm
describing now of getting tenure at MIT
that that's the key attribute to it and
then same sense
um if you take the sort of outliers
students were talking about you know 99
out of 100 come to me and say your work
is very fascinating I'd be interesting
to work
um for you and one out of a hundred come
and say
um here you're wrong here here here's
your mistake here's here's what you
should have been doing yeah
um and uh that they just sort of say I'm
here and and get to work and again
that's I I don't know how far this
resource goes so you know I've said I
consider the world's greatest resource
this engine of Brighton event of people
of which we only see a tiny little
Iceberg of it and everywhere we open
these labs they come out of the woodwork
they come we didn't create all these
educational programs all these other
things I'm describing we tried to
partner everywhere with local schools
and local companies and kept tripping
over dysfunction and find we had to
create the environment where people like
this can flourish and so I don't know if
this is everyone if it's one percent of
society what the fraction is but it's so
many orders of magnitude bigger than we
see today you know we've been racing to
keep up with it to take advantage of
that resource if something tells me it's
a very large fraction of the population
I mean the thing that gives me most hope
for the future is that population once a
year this whole Lab Network meets and
it's my favorite Gathering it's in
Bhutan this year because it's it's every
body shape it's every language every
geography but it's the same person in
all those packages it's it's the same
sense of bright inventive joy and
discovery
if there's people listening to this in
there just uh overwhelmed with how
exciting this is which I think they
would be how can they participate how
can they help how can they encourage
young people or themselves to uh to
build stuff to create stuff yeah that's
a great question so
um the
the this is part of a much bigger maker
movement that has a lot a lot of
embodiments the part I've been involved
in this Fab Lab Network you can think of
as a curated part that works as a
network so you don't benefit in a gym if
somebody exercises in another gym but in
the Fab Network and if you do in a sense
benefit when somebody works in another
Network another lab in the way it
functions as a network so
um you can come to
cba.mit.edu to see the research we're
talking about
um there's a Fab Foundation run by
Sherry Lasseter at fabfoundation.org Fab
Labs IO is a portal into the slab
Network
um uh Fab academy.org is this
distributed Hands-On educational program
fab.city is the platform of cities
producing what they consume those are
all nodes in this network so you can
learn with Fab Academy and you can
perhaps launch or help launch or
participate in launching a Fab Lab well
an in particular
um from one to a thousand we carefully
counted Labs now we're going from a
thousand to a million where it ceases to
become interesting to count them and in
the Thousand to the million
uh what's interesting about that stage
is uh technologically you go to a lab
not to get access to the machine but you
go to the lab to make the machine
but the other thing interesting in it
is we have an interesting collaboration
on a a Fab Lab in a box
and
um this came out of a collaboration with
SolidWorks on how you can put a Fab Lab
in a box which is not just the tools but
the knowledge so you open the box and
the box contains the knowledge of how to
use it as well as the tools within it
so that the knowledge can propagate and
so we have an interesting group of
people working on you know the original
Fab Labs which have a whole team to get
involved in the setting up and training
and the Fab Academy is a real in-depth
deep technical program in the training
but in this next phase how sort of the
lab itself knows how to do the lab that
that it's you know it we've talked
deeply about the intelligence in
fabrication but in a much more
accessible one about how the the the the
AI in the lab in effect becomes a
collaborator with you in this nearer
term to help get started and for for
people
wanting to connect it can seem like a
big step a big threshold but we've
gotten to thousands of these and they're
doubling
exactly that way just from people opting
in
and uh in so doing driving towards this
kind of idea of uh personal digital
fabrication yeah and it's not Utopia
it's not free but come back to today
we separately have education
we have big business we have startups
we have entertainment sort of each of
these things are segregated when you
have Global Connection to one of these
local facilities in that you can do play
and art and education and create
infrastructure
um you can make many of the things you
consume you could make it for yourself
it could be done on a community skull it
could be done on a regional scale
um it really I'd say
the research we spent the last few hours
talking about I thought was hard and in
a sense
I mean it's it
it's non-trivial but in a sense it's
just sort of playing out we're turning
the crank what I didn't think was hard
is
if anybody can make almost anything
anywhere
how do you live how do you learn how do
you work how you play these very basic
assumptions about how Society functions
there's a way in which it's kind of Back
to the Future
in that
this mode where work is money is
consumption and consumption is shopping
by selecting is only a kind of a few
decade old stretch
um in some ways we're getting back to
you know a a Sami Village in North
Norway is deeply sustainable
but rather than just reverting to living
the way we did a few thousand years ago
being connected globally having the
benefits of modern society but
connecting it back to older Notions of
sustainability
um I I hadn't remotely anticipated
just how fundamentally that challenges
how a society functions and how
interesting and how hard it is to figure
out how we can make that work and it's
possible that this kind of process
will give a deeper sense of meaning to
each person let me violently agree in in
two ways one way is uh
this community making
crosses many sensitive sectarian
boundaries in many parts of the world
where there's just you know implicit or
explicit conflict but sort of this act
of making
seems to transcend a lot of historical
divisions I don't say that
philosophically I just say that as an
observation and I think
there's something really fundamental in
what you said which is you know deep in
our brain is shaping our environment
um
a lot of what's strange about our
society is the way that we can't do that
the act of shaping our environment
touches something really really deep
that gets to the essence of Who We Are
you know that's again why I say that in
a way the most important thing made in
made in these Labs is making itself
what do you think
if the shaping of our environment gets
something deep what do you think is the
meaning of it all what's the meaning of
life now
I can tell you
my insights into how life works
I can tell you in my insights and how to
make life meaningful and fulfilling
and sustainable
um
I have no idea what the meaning of life
is but maybe that's the meaning of life
now the uncertainty the confusion of
um because there's a magic to it all
everything you've talked about from
starting from the basic elements with
the big bang that somehow created the
Sun that somehow uh said Fu to uh
thermodynamics and created life and all
the ways that you've talked about from
ribosomes that created the Machinery
that created the machine and then now
the biological machine creating
through digital fabrication more complex
artificial machines all of that there's
a magic to that creative process and we
notice we humans are smart enough to
notice the magic so it's you haven't
said the s word yet
um which one is that singularity
[Laughter]
yeah I'm not sure if Ray Kurzweil is
listening if he is high Ray but I have a
complex relationship with Rey because a
lot of the things he projects I find
annoying
but then he does his homework and then
somewhat annoyingly he points out how
almost everything I'm doing fits on his
road maps yeah
um and so
you know the
the the
question is are we heading towards the
singularity I
so I'd have to say I lean towards
sigmoids rather than exponentials
um we've done pretty well with the
sigmoids yeah so sigmoids are things
grow and they taper and then there can
be one after it and one after it so
um
you know I'll pass on whether there's
enough of them that that they diverge
but you know to
the selfish Gene answer to the meaning
of life is the meaning of life is the
propagation of life and so
um
you know it it it was a step for S atoms
to assemble into a molecule
for molecules to assemble into a
protocell for the protocell to form to
then form organelles for the organ cells
to form organs the organs to form an
organism then it was a step for
organisms to form family units then
family units to form Villages you can
view you know each of those as a stack
in the level of organizations so you
could view everything we've spoken about
as
the imperative of life
just the next step in the hierarchy of
that and the Fulfillment of the
inexorable Drive of the violation of
thermodynamics so you know you could
view you know I'm an embodiment of the
will of the violation of thermodynamics
speaking
the two of us having having an old chat
yes yeah
um and so continues and even then the
singularity is just a transition up the
ladder there's nothing deeper to
Consciousness than it it it's a derived
property of distributed problem solving
um there's nothing deeper to life than
embodied AI
in morphogenesis
so why so much of this conversation in
my life is
involved in these Fab labs and initially
it just started as Outreach then it
started as keeping up with it
then it turned to
uh
it was rewarding then it turned to we're
learning as much from these labs in as
goes out to them it began as Outreach
but now more knowledge is coming back
from the labs that is going into them
um and then finally it ends with
um
you know what I described as competing
with myself at MIT but a better way to
say that is tapping the brain power of
the planet
and so from I guess for me personally
that's the meaning of my life
and maybe that's the meaning for the
universe too it's uh it's using us
humans and our Creations to understand
itself
in a way it's uh
whatever the creative process that
created Earth
is competing with itself
yeah so you could take morphogenesis as
a summary of this whole conversation or
you could take recursion
that that in a sense what we've been
talking about is recursion all the way
down and in the end I think uh this
whole thing is pretty fun it's short
life is but it's pretty fun and so is
this conversation you know I mentioned
you offline them going through some
difficult stuff personally and your
passion for what you do is just really
inspiring and it just uh lights up my
mood and lights up my heart and your
inspiration for I know
thousands of people that work with unmit
and millions people across the world
it's a big honor to use it with me today
this is really fun this was a pleasure
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Neil gershenfeld to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you with some words from
Pablo Picasso
every child is an artist a challenge is
staying an artist when you grow up
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time